presa tutti ragazzi e prevede che solo
video sono fa vj che oggi siamo in un
nuovo blog
prima di cominciare volevo dirvi una
cosa da questo blog questo blog lo
voglio farlo avete già visto forse dalla
copertina in collaborazione con la xx
century fox per chiarimenti e uscì sta
per uscire film di kings man è che un
film bello e la twenty century fox mi ha
chiesto di fare di essere un kings man
in questo video quindi di impersonare il
protagonista che sarebbe tipo tipo james
bond mettiamola così e per farlo ragazzi
serve uno smoking un vestito che io in
genere non mi metto perché vado in giro
così con tanto di ascelle e mi ha
contattato come la tua enti century fox
per chiedermi di partecipare
all'esperienza strictu elite che sarebbe
per la promozione del film di kings deve
fantastico perché vorrei mettermi mi
vogliono farmi non so parlare oggi hanno
voluto far indossare uno smoking a me un
po più a me cosa impossibile
rassomigliare il protagonista del film
di fim man che dovrebbe essere un figo
che sa combattere uno che sa parlare uno
che sa a rimorchiare le donne e quindi
ho deciso ragazzi di fare questo blog
con un vestito uno smoking guardarmi
dati minori da di chi diavolo è sto
tizio vi faccio vedere la clip del film
da commento tipo gameplay per niente ai
ragazzi dovrebbe stir mi più o meno come
come quel tizio come questa ecco questo
qua c'è gente che si ammazzano fermati
ma ecco tipo questo bel ma porca put ha
inizio niente c'è gente ma ecco questo
qui
dopo i vestiti quindi tipo lui cosa che
non è da mere per farlo devo andare in
un posto dove mi trasformano in un kings
man è namase
[Musica]
mi piace sta con te solo che ciò
leggermente caldo pro ok ragazzi
partiamo perché sa veramente divento
vecchio quaderno bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti che sono video sono fa vj oggi
siamo il nuovo blog prima di cominciare
cosa sente di ripartire con la fanar
della settimana che questa settimana è
stata vinta da allora io prima di farvi
vedere la fa nat mi spiegate come come
cazzo si dovrebbe pronunciare questo lo
spiegate ma credo si pronunci cia
tacciata qualcosa del genere a chiamarti
tipo maria no comunque variate distanza
bravi nell di uno dei disegni migliori
che abbia mai visto ma mi sale
leggermente la paura vedere st non so
perché passiamo alle news che è meglio
prima continui a fissare questa foto e
muoia o chi agassi diagnosi importante
gli volevo dare che non posso dirvi
ancora perché vi è una sorpresa diciamo
potrebbe potrebbe non lo so ma potrebbe
essere c'è nei prossimi video non so
quando ripeto potrebbe essere che tipo
lo sfondo questo mio bella mia camera
non ci sia più per un pochettino di tep
non lo so perché forse dovrò registrare
non più dalla mia camera ma in un'altra
camera
voi vi spiegherò perché che gesto fatto
bellissimo una volta mi è capitato di
fare un video che non era in camera mia
sarà la gente col taglierino così cena
roba ok quindi lo dico prima e prima che
muoia qualcuno i ragazzi possiamo uno
scarto dei pacchi prima che questo
vestito possa prendere il controllo
legno cervello cosa che sta per
succedere a chi era che allora no tana
no questo è da dove spuntato è saltato
dal pavimento vado ma questo prima che è
spuntato a casa voglio capire cos'è
andato sembra un rotolo di carta
igienica finito solo che era la carta
igienica di godzilla
capiamoci ragazzi perché i giornali
nelle h nella carta igienica dovrebbe
essere fuori la carta non dentro
maledizione cos'è cos'è questo cioè
diventa un power rangers e lo picco non
ho capito è cosa ragazzi ma ci sono 700
giornali sono una persona felice una fan
alta della madonna ramello la cosa più
bella di questo disegno in assoluto è
questo che cosa cazzo dovrebbe essere
attuato o mio dio
oh mio dio è una presa per il culo qui
serio mi hai fatto un kit mario di
dimensioni più grosso di me star o della
carta igienica questo scritto fuori
certifica che faccio pagare zio nomadi
di melo mi è cascato dico c'è un limite
a tutto ragazzi mi sono già spinto oltre
per questo c'è un fiocco nava per questo
questo devo mettere adesso vi prego
massa prossimo perché è grazie sto bene
così agevole sì c'è certo ma tutto io lo
sapevo che non sarei riuscito a tenere
un minimo di dignità in questo video una
vagonata di braccialetti sei un altro un
altro pacco un altro punto certo perché
vi mettiamo noi mettiamo i pacchi nei
pacchi ma oggi come ultima perché gli
ultimi fatti sono sempre più strani ma
spiegatemi certe cose è stato l'altro è
bellissimo come è finito cioè perfetto e
avete presente il discorso che ho fatto
prima sulla dignità del video ecco fermi
un attimo fantastico ragazzo e poi c'è
una c'è anche una molla trova meglio i
ragazzi vi amo abbiate paghiamo e quindi
ragazzine che possiamo passare al farvi
dispone io lo faccio costi occhiali fa
vi risponde giusto per vedere di belle
che vi sono bastati cinque minuti per
ridurmi così e tristezza questa si
chiama tristezza prima di cominciare a
fare risponde ragazzi volevo farmi
vedere una cosa epica che mi è successa
recentemente avete presente la smart con
non ce la faccio ragazzi se continuo
così finisco il video che veramente gli
occhi escono così aree presenti e lounge
pub quello con cui faccio le basi
dubstep mentre lo utilizzavo
praticamente miss e scassata la cassa e
non è partito più l'audio e la reazione
è stata bellissima
devo farvela vedere scusatemi ma devo
queste sono le mie capacità da esperto
in queste cose è comunque non c'entra un
cazzo ma doveva assolutamente metterla
perché meritava la prima domanda arriva
da james jones hi fi
farai la testa piccola ciò vi risponde
fa vs nella nutella il tuo simbolo
distintivo pensieri li guardavo assieme
e tutti i ragazzi in questi giorni come
cazzo si spegne sta merda 8 anche un
post su facebook perché ci tenevo che è
morto il creatore della nutella cioè
colui che ha inventato la nutella e
quindi niente volevo dedicare un
pezzettino del blog semplicemente per
ricordare questo genio perché vedete ci
ha fatto tanto e anche mio compaesano
nel senso e di torino una città vicino a
torino io utilizzo sempre la frase tipo
dov'è la nutella quando gioco nel nei
videogiochi quindi devo anche uno dei
miei motti anche lui ci tenevo a
dedicare questo momento serio a lui
perché ho un rispetto nei confronti
veramente incredibile spero che comunque
anzi di sicuro sia in un posto migliore
adesso è anche più dolce come ha scritto
su facebook perché ovviamente avrà
portato la nutella tutti i ragazzi è
finito al momento serio posto riprendono
mai più nella vita in questo video sei
piu figo del solito perché
[Musica]
ok la smetto perché mi sento un
deficiente però poi risponde favi inizia
il video inizio siamo un pò tardi prova
inizia vito evitando l'uomo ragno
ok
[Musica]
per cosa ragazzine che possono includere
chi con i favori sponde scusate ma c'è
un caldo bestiale
voglio provare a fare una famiglia manda
diverso perché stavolta vale allora ecco
che su questo abito qualche tipo voglio
provare ragazzi a fare un premio o con
questi occhiali qui o con questo vestito
non lo so un qualche cosa
inter mi vuoi che cosa volete che faccia
un voglio provare a farlo nel prossimo
blog
se riesco però qualcosa di fattibile è
prima di qualcuno e ragazzi devo tornare
alle mie sembianze perché a me che posso
stare così per tutta la vita
scusatemi un attimo
e che cazzo mortacci tua
mi sono anche certo di capelli vedo
tutto diverso no rivoglio i miei poteri
li voglio essere figo stata
un'esperienza bellissima per la prima
volta nella mia vita è satura mente figo
ragazzi sono chi è bisogna tornare
esseri umani anche dopo essere stati
kings man con ragazzi apporto è tutto a
parte tutto sto casino investito la
kidman è stata una figata e riuscire a
essere a far parte di questo progetto
per il film di kings man è fantastico
perché in generale io amo i film così
perché c'è azione e mettermi nei panni
di kings bene è stato fantastico ci può
essere un figo come lui a portare questi
vestiti come nel film è un casino non è
veramente mi sembra di essere in una
camicia di forza non va beh non proprio
così però ringrazio tutti per aver reso
possibile questa cosa vi regalo questi
occhiali quindi ragazzi quando vedrete
il film ricordatevi che io gli ho io
sono stato io a vestirmi c'è io ero più
bello di lui quindi ricordatevi questa
cosa già sto facendo quindi ragazzi se
il video è piaciuto e cosa aspettarsi al
trattamento mi piace anche a passati
facebook e come ogni video trattano
descrizione ce l'avresti ti schianti
riuscirvi devono prossimo ok così è
meglio l ci vediamo non fosse non vedo
un cazzo con questi è accaduto tutto
bella ragazza